Oh
I don't think anybody should care about
the gossip I put on my site you know you
don't have to read it the great thing
about it is it's I like to think of my
website is like the mcdonalds of the
internet a lot of people love to
criticize McDonald's but yeah it's still
really popular and i love the french
fries
I think gossip is people's interest in
gossip is nothing new it's been around
for decades it's been around for
centuries the only thing that's changed
is the media has become aware that
celebrity news can be profitable so
gossip or celebrity news is now
mainstream news
I don't know but I know that the
celebrity news is mainstream news I know
that Anderson Cooper has discussed
Lindsay Lohan many times and he probably
hates it but you know what he will
continue to discuss about celebrity news
and he will continue to talk about
Lindsay Lohan
I would not insult the mainstream news
by saying that it's a form of glorified
gossip no I still think that mainstream
news is very valuable invaluable
mainstream news is just doing their job
if they weren't making money they
wouldn't be able to provide us with the
news so they have to have that celebrity
element there so they can get ratings
but you know not all the times that you
know there are those shows that have
nothing to do with politics but there's
been a shift definitely over the last
five or ten years where there is a lot
more celebrity content in mainstream
news
I think celebrity news is only a
positive thing I look at it as
aspirational it's a great escape for
people and a lot of them love to
fantasize ago wouldn't it be great if I
were famous too wouldn't it be great if
I could go to that shop and buy that
fancy clothes that Kim Kardashian buys